[Music]
and we're spoiled at news submitted by
tips Harris flawless shiny did you send
a woman's boyfriend bought flowers for
her friend by Twitter ruined a what I
think I know where this is going they
ruined the supplies so I imagine you
guys are out and you buy her flowers
yeah and then you're just nice and then
you buy TIFF flowers because she's there
and she doesn't have her boyfriend there
her husband and you're just like oh hey
lady yo for her and for her and Twitter
was like Oh Hannah why is he giving her
flowers too
that's so good I like that that's a good
theory so it's 21 year old college
students she ended up posting this on
Twitter so she wrote my best friend was
cheated on by her boyfriend and my
boyfriend bought her flowers just to
show her that she deserves better than a
cheater
he knows if he's dating me he's dating
my friend oh when your BFF boyfriend
buys you flowers it's cute I don't like
that what Steve would do that right all
right I feel like people do that like
this is a girl and her boyfriend not a
best friend that is cute but I guess I
just pictured a different because all
for example when we go out like at the
bicyclops there's always a lady selling
flowers so I like for example Danny's
like the only guy that I think my
boyfriend's the only one that hangs out
with all of us so he'll buy all of us
flowers like to help the lady out yes
nice yeah so that's not like a big deal
I don't really care my friends are
posting their flowers on Instagram I'm
like yeah girl get him jellies but I
then you would do that too I guess but I
don't know it's just Korean what's
cringy about it I guess no Twitter ruin
that I don't get it either because those
flowers aren't even [ __ ] me flowers I
think I know what bothered me that
they're very friendship well if he's
dating me he's dating my friends wasn't
necessarily rub people the wrong leg
where I'm like oh those have you heard
it sounds like if you want to be my
lover you gotta [ __ ] all my friends not
fun no that's not how it goes be that's
a British thing yeah they do harem sex
okay so she ended up getting
lot of dick hate all for this yeah that
last sentence was unnecessary it was
until then for that you can [ __ ] all my
friends so then there were people saying
like my boyfriend will not be giving my
friend what when you date me you date my
friend why are you talking like that
word cuz I want to make it creepy
oh you succeeding cute you're [ __ ]
all of us cuz we're cold who your
girlfriend's [ __ ] all of us know
anyone that dates anybody they're dating
the family like that you don't get it JK
is a [ __ ] cult yeah okay yes okay
okay I thought it was like you and all
your personalities you're dating jungle
Joe you're dating gambler Joe you're TV
which I'm good Joe I like that alright
so then some people responded with like
yeah my boyfriend will not be giving my
best friend flowers and he got retweeted
over 16,000 times this other one said
that's sweet but who's gonna buy you
flowers when they're they end up
smashing what he will no one they don't
get it they push it too far or they're
just like insecure and their own really
yeah but just the last sentence like if
he's dating me he's dating my friends I
can't [ __ ] with that like no you didn't
mean to say that yeah no no where people
are really so then they're like well
this is the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever seen
another one said take it too literally
ters also like savage though like you're
I like Twitter me too I like it too but
you can put like a dime would be like
why don't you put a [ __ ] common it's
crazier than Instagram it's hilarious I
[ __ ] love Twitter yeah so then there
were other people like this one said I
have no issue about this if I had a
boyfriend and they did this for my
friend I'd find it thoughtful and kind
those who think oh he must want her or
he's he's cheating on her need to heal
you allow people to be kind but they're
like eat or they never had a vagina and
their life a bagina vagina
no one said if your friendships are
healthy and your relationship is healthy
you would understand the pure love in
this I just don't buy flowers period so
I guess I'm out of the whole thing you
bought them involuntary I saw who's
gonna say
stop backing tough oh my god use it oh
my god it was my friend's company they
said shut up Joe Oh [ __ ] compliment
you always bought that but yeah so yeah
it's like it's just the people's
insecurities and the last time or that
said that they've never had any good
people in their lives
yeah yeah like for sure absolutely you
say that's that's that's what I had to
tell him that not buy me flowers this
year why because he thinks that grocery
store flowers are like less than so he
goes and buys this like crazy bouquet
and I'm like we don't need any so I was
like give me a traitor's Jose okay if
you're gonna get me fine you know what
something I mean I think it's really
cute that he does that but something
thoughtful my my cousin told me she was
like you know like you never really
wanna and maybe you guys can chime in on
this like you don't really want to tell
them man like oh don't do that because
eventually they'll stop you know cuz
they're like what she doesn't appreciate
ours you know I tell them how much I
[ __ ] love flower visit but I'm like I
like them whether they're in a bow or if
they're in like the plants and the
amount of money spent is honest yeah
because the thought is what I like
thought that he like went to the store
picked out flowers for me he's like I
think she'll like this kind yeah that's
what was like really thought yeah true
yeah same but the ones he used to pick
out we're pretty tight they were like
covered in like pearl like fake pearls
yeah like really pretty really pretty
presented yeah that's cool we recently
started this thing where Casey picks up
flowers from the grocery store and now
we we have to bouquet bouquets and one
of them is in the bedroom and the other
ones in the dining room so then wherever
I go there's oh I love that you have it
too so every week or every like how long
do they last like a week and yeah two
weeks yeah then we change it I just
carry mine I'm like I'm going to feel
like I won
I told you and like I literally have
like if I when are you working in the
kitchen I just put it there if I'm gonna
go to sleep I put him over there yeah
but I don't know I just don't like to
separate them because what have they
died faster or something I think it
separated yeah like separation anxiety
and then I can't be away from offense
like that Danny gets like he's like you
recently started doing this thing where
like he'll see something he likes online
and he'll take it like he'll tell his
flower girl like recreate this oh that's
cool like this last one looks like
wrapped it I think it was like yes a
flower girl yeah I do like a like a lady
who does the flowers just just to get
you gifts all the time I mean I don't
know if he's known her for a long time
but he tells me like all your texts on
my flower girl and I'm good in the
flower girl I mean that's pretty legit
cuz that's like having a suit person
yeah yeah like they just make custom
[ __ ] for you well he lives in LA so I
think there's so many flower shops
people I just knows the same lady yeah
yeah yeah Mexicans have so many chances
of getting flowers my kids in Euros like
communion like there's like there's just
so many events I think that happen in a
year is there a lot of flower giving in
the culture in Mexico yeah man Mexican
men tend to be very like giving like we
want I want to show you yeah they even
hire a whole life fund that's to come
and perform for the leg side and Metta
yeah they just got so many events that
there's so many chances to have flowers
they just take the middle thingy and
Asian men are hella giving but I'm just
bad at being Asian don't buy you jewelry
they'll buy your [ __ ] don't [ __ ] try
to buy that [ __ ] for life that's high
high level no but listen I told them
like instead of spending money on this
jewelry spend it on experience that's
exactly what I say so mysterion
like me like a monster or yeah that we
can enjoy together or a skydiving trip
literally anything to do with
experiences I'm like [ __ ] yeah
Oh cuz I bet your love language is
quality time it is yeah see Sam actually
yeah an escape room that's something
that's like the opaque dinner for my
birthday last year that was awesome
because in excuse care the dark and you
guys were all get out but you dragged us
in a [ __ ] terrifying moment no it was
a pitch pitch black dinner yeah yeah
there was a hair of us I don't know I
couldn't see the hair tasted it yeah you
were like yeah you can't see anything
server's doing probably no one the
server told us the story of how he got
by were all about to die laughing he
told us he got live from throwing up
ceviche yeah and then the next [ __ ]
ditch was ceviche ceviche and he got
food poisoning that he threw up so hard
his retinas got detached from the
eyeball he said don't ever throw up
bending over you always throws like
standing we're like like squatting I'm a
stand-up comedians I'm gonna start
laughing right now that was pretty funny
it's [ __ ] crazy that is a real thing
though yeah like the pressure builds up
Felix I have money in your ceviche
basically didn't say that but but that's
so [ __ ] up first of all I'm not gonna
throw up like that anymore but come on
all the times you were drunk and like
throwing up like that don't go bend over
and throw up dude squats Wow I did squat
every time I you got a squat barely
stand so yeah anyway we were talking
about flowers here yeah the boyfriend
giving the flowers I don't know I
thought it was sweet yeah I know what
that's not unlike to me it sounds like
um you know how like when you when a
guide dates a girl you're also kind of
trying to win the approval of her
friends yeah yeah so it sounds like that
like when you date me but day my friends
it's almost like you gotta be extruding
all the thing is here is that
Abigale which is the girlfriend she says
that her boyfriend is like good friends
with her best friend whose name is
Stephanie I believe and so she was just
like so initially the boyfriend asked
add the gal if Affairs if it was okay to
send her flowers because I she was
heartbroken now and then she was like
yeah I didn't think it would come off
creepy or overstepping especially since
they're close friends so she's she was
like not that it was really sweet you
just have to be okay on Twitter like
hearing hundreds of [ __ ] opinions and
be so securing your relationship they
were like y'all trippin like this is
nothing it's just sad that people like
get ya like they have nothing going on
their lives but people won't literally
turn anything into something negative
you don't like the interesting opinions
I just think it's different but I mean
this is so aggressive I should feel
people's energies when they get mad at
stupid [ __ ] I'm like why are you taking
life sucks but don't you laugh at how
what a loser they are I don't like that
I feel like it's more spending time
racing I laugh when they when people
roast people with like funny memes I
think that's just funny as [ __ ] but like
when people get so like I would never
let my man through that and you know
they get like sorry in their face like
damn it's like watching
oh my god
[Music]